- Hey, it's somethin' I love about you-
- Look it's your dog!
- Oh, is my dog here?
- I love him!
- That's my dog, Henry. (laughs)
Hey, Henry!
- He's mad at me!
- He's laying down back
there, he's my old man.
But anyway-
- Mine is my boyfriend!
- I love it, I love it!
So one thing I love about you
and it's a similarity between
us is I love an oily throat
when I'm in the studio singing.
And I heard that like
when I'm in the studio,
I have to have, this is
the weirdest thing ever.
I order two hash browns
from McDonald's. (laughs)
- (indistinct) so good.
- And I just lube it up!
And that's my thing.
(guest laughs)
And I heard that you
have like, is it bacon?
- Well see, remember, they used
to say that Aretha Franklin,
rest in peace, I love her so much,
she used to eat potato chips.
- Potato chips, and
then I've heard chicken
because Babyface told me that
when we first worked together,
and I was like,
I can't even believe
I'm talking to Babyface
and he's talking about Aretha Franklin,
and her process (indistinct) with my life.
But yeah, no, I heard that it's the same,
she gets soul food, like in there.
'Cause it just a greases it up,
and it kind of lubes it up, it's nice.
- (laughs) Lubes it up, girl.
- Oh, sorry!
I didn't mean it like that. (laughs)
- Mine is hot dogs with
bacon wrapped around it.
With like spicy mustard,
and I'd just be so happy.
- My mouth is watering.